hello world by all means this isn't so
much of VM as a machine that is less
underpowered than the netbook I normally
carry around with me this netbook has
many hours of battery life it's
extremely portable and it's powered up
it's powered by a wind-up toy so if I
actually do test builds for you we'd be
here a while
all right I pretty much am forced to
start let me see did I decide to go with
index or index - I think index - yeah
six of one half dozen the other I'm
pretty much forced to start with the
concept of circular dependencies when
you are building a Linux system if
you've ever installed things there are
often other prerequisite packages well
when you get down far enough the
dependencies become circular you can't
install a system without boot media a
USB or CD to boot it from you can't
create a boot media without having a
running system you know way back in the
dark ages we had punched cards and paper
tape that you could physically write
information - or the switches on the
front of the Altair that you know you
could flip here's the address here's the
here's the value the right button and
you could literally toggle in a program
if you had hours to do it that went away
a long time ago we now have you know
millions of bytes of stuff and when
you're putting together a system
something you're going to hit a lot
especially if you ever deal with
something like Linux from scratch is you
have to build packages before you can
build other packages and in order to
avoid bits of the host system leaking
into the target you sometimes have to
build something that you're not actually
going to install but you're going to
build against so we'll get to all that
but the reason I introduced with the
concept of circular dependencies is I
have spent two weeks attempting to come
up with a nice linear index of here's
the topics I want to cover in
this order and its circular dependencies
all the way down so we're going to be
explaining some stuff and then coming
back to explain why that was incomplete
or wrong a little later
all right so circular dependencies so
there are four I mean there are four
basic components of a build environment
of a Linux system that's capable of
rebuilding itself under itself from
source code those four are a kernel a C
library a set of command line utilities
and a tool chain and a tool chain is
what all the embedded geeks call a
compiler and linker and the make program
the set of build utilities that actually
let you compile stuff when you are
creating a system though it doesn't have
to be able to rebuild itself under
itself your your tiny little embedded
ones generally don't so your build time
packages and your runtime packages one
of the ways that you break circular
dependencies is by separating them okay
one of the things I did as okay one of
the things I did is backstory to this a
long time ago is starting like 15 years
ago I created a project called
Aboriginal Linux from the Latin
Aborigine from the beginning where
basically I started with Linux from
scratch and I went okay what is the
smallest simplest build environment I
can get capable of building itself from
source code those four packages I talked
about our conceptual packages I got it
down to seven actual packages which were
the Linux kernel you see Lib C at the
time make bash bin utils GCC and I list
them here
and busybox and in order to make that
work I wound up actually maintaining
busybox for a while because I did so
much work with you know if I want to
replace the canoe version of said with
busybox said it didn't work so I
upgraded it to the point where you know
I upgraded their sort command I upgraded
their mount command and it got the point
where the previous maintainer just
handed it off to me for a couple years
and then I hand it off to Dennis was Inc
oh but busybox has had a lot of work
over the years to make it provide the
set of command line utilities all in one
package and that was an explicit goal
that took years of work the others you
know the tool chain I used at the time
was Binh utils plus GCC plus make so
three packages there and by the way even
busybox at the time I was substituting
in bash for its shell because I never
got around to upgrading at shell that's
why there's a 7th package there busybox
has had some work on its shell since
then and it's possible that you could
build Linux from scratch with busybox
ash these days I haven't tried it
recently this was an old version of GCC
that had been utils in GCC as two
packages now they've metastasized to
five packages you know so the simplest
system with modern packages is less
simple than previous systems were fun
stuff Linux is still Linux for a while
Linux needed Perl to build because Peter
and v'n decided that was a thing into
625 and it took me several years of
submitting patches to remove Perl as a
build requirement before that finally
went away in like 2013 ok so let me
start by the simplest thing you can do
to boot a system is
yeah because I'm in the wrong see yeah I
haven't the intro phone nope okay so how
simple what can we get here is a page
where someone booted HelloWorld on the
bare metal okay and you can easily
Google for this or you can go to that
URL I'll post a list of the URLs I went
to after the talk but basically what
what he did is he has a little function
that just repeatedly writes to the the
output register of the serial port and
has that iterate through a string and
then specially builds it with a little
assembly header and with a linker script
that puts stuff in the right place does
this stuff which you know the assembler
GCC for the C part linker running
special linker script and then a program
called object that takes it from the elf
format and copies it to a binary it
basically the elf format is a bit like
zip or like tar it's an archive format
for storing executable data so there's a
variant of elf that stores shared
libraries there's a variant of elf that
stores dynamically linked programs is a
variant of elf that stores dynamic
statically linked programs it's
basically the same archive with
different header information and what
this does is this extracts just the raw
binary blob output format binary and
puts it to test up bin and one of the
things I did is Hello Hardware make Sh
the other thing I have to introduce is
the concept of cross compilers we'll get
to that I mentioned circular
dependencies and so if I run make that
Sh which I ran on that machine and the
paths are
different of course
may see him - ha there I have it
so this is actually the machine I also
crossed make to put let's try that now
Hey so that just compiled the the
programming created a test bin and then
run is copied from his thing where we
call QEMU system arm till it machine
versatile PB is one of the arm systems
qmu no time you like does anybody here
not know what qemu is okay
kiwi mu is an emulator it's a program
that creates a virtual machine and runs
the code you feed into it it has a
built-in bootloader where basically can
go this file copy it into the virtual
memory and jump to the start of it you
know if it's in an own format it can
actually read the header on it and go oh
this is an elf file I'll do basically
what object did copy into memory myself
and jump to the start information out of
the header here we already did the
objects so you know the bare metal one
the - kernel test bin argument is
basically telling it use your built-in
boot loader to load this into the
virtual machines memory
- no graphics says instead of popping up
a window with the bitmap output of your
emulated video card you know whatever
the program that's running wrote into
the EM you know it tried to access the
emulated hardware and it's it's driver
intercepted that and wrote it into the
window instead of doing that just have a
serial port on on the standard in and
standard out of the qemu program so that
whatever you write to qemu standard in
goes to the serial port and whatever the
serial port you know whatever the
REM writes back to the serial port goes
to standard out of QEMU so that you can
actually you know interact with it on
QEMU standard in and you can actually do
things like use tickle to script
emulator instances that way it's it's
very useful the dash M 128 M says 128
megabytes of memory is how much should
be installed into the virtual machine
this says basically what motherboard to
emulate what board board is shorthand
for for motherboard it basically says
put this processor input memory at this
location all the information about you
know all the information that would be
in device tree when we get to that you
know all the information that the kernel
needs to know where to look for these
devices well qemu similarly needs to
know where to put the emulated versions
of them so we told it this is a common
type of very old arm board from I think
the 90s the verse are versatile board
and then this is just me telling it
don't attempt to emulate an audio device
because if you do it will spam standard
out with a bunch of I failed to to
connect to OSS and it's like I just
don't want that so when I do that I get
hello world it booted a virtual system
which wrote something to the serial port
and then just spun okay so this is about
the simplest thing you can get a machine
to do and actually see the output and my
fan is starting up because it is
spinning you'll notice there's a CPU
pinned and the other fun thing about
this is we're now going to tell you why
it's wrong and the reason that it's
wrong is
oh come on I have it in here somewhere
the reason that it's wrong is that real
serial Hardware only works at a certain
rate you know it has a UART buffer that
can fill up if you just spin writing to
its output register it's going to start
discarding data fairly quickly what you
need to do is you need to read a status
register that will have a bit set that
says I am ready for the next byte or not
and you can actually fetch that out of
the Linux kernel source code in it's
under drivers yeah TTY serial Amba PL 0
1 1 dot C and then put
yeah console put character it's doing a
read from a register and anding it and
while it's doing that you know CPU relax
is basically a way of telling the
processor not to overheat it's it's a no
op that takes a little extra time and
then write the character once it frees
up so you note that a driver attempting
to talk to real Hardware is doing an
extra step that the emulator is not
doing and we're going to hit that a few
times in here but the really fun thing
about this this PL 0:11 console put care
is a Linux driver that's designed to
work before interrupts have been enabled
early in the Linux boot process early
print kay we'll get to configuring the
kernel in a little bit and that means
that before linux has really initialized
most of the other hardware it may want
to print stuff out very very early on
which means if you know what your serial
hardware is and where it's configured
you can basically look up what these
macros are and substitute in the
constants and cut and paste a liner to
that let you stick print statements into
anywhere you can stick it into a
bootloader you can stick it into early
boot you can truly debug almost anything
with print statements you know so that's
actually a nice little technique to have
in your back pocket and we will get back
to that so the other thing that's wrong
with that is we're doing the simplest
possible Linux system and clearly hello
world is not Linux
so let's actually do what it says on the
tin and I should have done that
beforehand because I want to build for
10
I don't know how slow the you know the
net here is gonna be too slow all right
can't give me 49 I don't know when the
next time last time I did a poll on this
machine was alright so the other thing
other than circular dependencies is
we're going to have to define simplest
what I'm going to show you right now is
the simplest way to build a Linux system
hello what are you doing where you at
random thing in 2016 yeah right
lovely many others
I have a bunch of others
well here's 3/5 right sure that's
ancient still works the same way though
did you fit yep what the downside of
switching to a much faster machine right
before the thing is my careful setup I
ran through is right there yes
the 4.9 4.9 there we go all right so
it's gonna boil down to we're going to
do a
which of the yes I know all right did I
put it in here sure okay the theory
behind building a kernel always boils
down to you're going to do a make config
you're going to do a make and then you
you install and boot the result a lot of
the times we're going to be cross
compiling cross come the the difference
between native compiling and cross
compiling is something that I'm going to
explain on an x86 64 system we're going
to start with the available def config
so if you go make help grep underscore
def config it should list for the
architecture you've selected the
available are you still checking out no
no you're not
come on there we go so it has a three by
three eighty-six def config which is
32-bit and x86 64 def config which is
64-bit if I selected a different
architecture there's a bunch of
architectures in the arch directory if I
selected you know make arch equals armed
I'm gonna get a whole bunch of defconn
fix but for right now the simplest way
of doing it is to build for the same
architecture as this thing to not deal
with cross compiling at all first and
I'm going to go make x86 64 def config
that's an underscore there I don't think
you can actually see it
seriously
there we go and then make two sj8 things
we're done okay you can do it make j8
and this is going to build an awful lot
of kernel and that's gonna go for a
while so meanwhile in another window the
reason I opened the second window
let's build a hello world binary
the reason for this instead of exiting
is that I'm gonna run this as PID 1 when
a Colonel boots it needs first it needs
a bootloader to have Run 2 loaded it to
load it into memory and there's a couple
of times that it can load run straight
around but we'll get to that then the
kernel needs to know the board layout
you know where to find the physical
memory where to find the serial port if
you're using a serial console where to
find the i/o devices even if you have
busses you can scan you need to know
what buses there are and where to find
them so it needs some starting data
before it can even scan the rest of the
system to see you know what's plugged
into USB well where's the USB controller
and then it needs a root filesystem in
order to load its first program from and
it needs the first program to run and
we're going to provide all those things
in the little system we put together
here we are going to use an it Rama fess
and we are going to use a statically
linked HelloWorld program as an it and
we're going to boot this under QEMU so
that you can see basically hello world
run in a different context so this is a
second layer of useless before we start
getting to actually useful now you'll
notice this is this is building it at a
reasonable clip you know this is an
eight-way SMP machine and it's still
building quite a lot the thing about def
config is it's got how many symbols
so that's 1164 that are just set to Y
actually okay there's the number that
are that are set so 1252 symbols which
select a lot of stuff you know we're not
going over all of these symbols we do
not have time so what we're going to do
instead you know
so make def config is simple to build it
is not going to result in the simplest
system I thought it would take less time
than this
and then to package this up we are going
to
[Music]
we are going to do this little
invocation find period - CPI Oh
Oh - H nu C pipe it is - gzip and we're
going to do that in the directory that
has our new root filesystem so you zip I
don't need actually need parentheses and
then redirect that to the directory
above this root cpio GZ so this has
created yeah I didn't I didn't strip
that that's statically linked against G
Lib C which means it's flipping enormous
and it even has the source code in there
but that won't that won't bother us when
the Linux kernel boots it starts by
mounting a root filesystem there are a
couple of ways you can specify where the
root filesystem lives
you can statically linked in a cpio
archive into the kernel binary which
will be extracted into memory in a file
system called an it Ram FS and it Rama
fess is an instance of either Ram FS or
temp FS in more recent ones dock
documentation file systems I years ago I
wrote documentation on this so if you
want to you know read through all that
this is just the very quick summary cpio
is an older archive format that predates
tar but still works just fine they used
it because it's simpler tar is actually
a lot more complicated under the covers
that gets extracted into ram FS Rama
fess is a ram based filesystem there's
four kinds of file systems there's block
backed which is the conventional ones
you're familiar with like ext - there's
a
there's a block device which is a fixed
amount of storage that gets formatted
and interpreted through a second driver
that tells that what kind of file system
there is there's pipe backed which are
called different things sometimes you
hear them as network file systems fuse
is another example of this where
basically you're talking through a pipe
to another program that speaks a
protocol and that other program is
providing your file system so that
program may be samba that program may be
you know there's a bunch of things it
could be pipe backed ones don't have to
be network file systems but people
usually think of that the point is that
it's a serial protocol the third kind
are the RAM backed file systems where
your your files are stored in memory
where basically the Linux disk cache the
page cache and the D entry cache that
store copies of the thought you know
copies of file data on their way to
whatever backing store there is because
if you're writing faster or if you've
read them in and it doesn't want to redo
the transaction with either the block
device or the server you know
the cache storing the data in the case
of RAM backed file systems has been
plugged so that there's nowhere to flush
the pages to when you write data into a
RAM based filesystem there's two
instances of them there's Rama fest and
tempo fest in the kernel when you write
it in there it it has nowhere to go so
it stays and when you delete the files
out of them it frees up the memory so
that they automatically resize
themselves to how much is actually being
used now note that the older Ram disk
that you've probably heard of isn't
actually a ram base filesystem it is a
block backed file system where you have
a device driver that turns a block of
memory into a block device it exposes it
in dev as slash dev slash Ram zero or
something like that and then you use a
second driver as the you know ext two or
vfat or something like that as the lens
you look at that block of memory through
you run a formatting program on it to
put it in you know the right format you
copy files into it and then you look at
it through a second driver that
is a convention that is a block-based
file system not a ram based file system
so a lot of people to this day still
confuse those RAM based file systems are
actually a lot more memory efficient
because the thing about a block-based
file system is you've got the copy in
the block device and then you've got
another copy in the page cache so it
actually you know it's actually less
memory efficient to use the older format
and a lot of people still don't
understand there's between those the
Fourth Kind is synthetic file systems
where there is no backing store when you
read files or you write files you're
talking to a driver that can do
arbitrary stuff with them proc is an
example of this Sisyphus is an example
of this the contents of proc are just
hallucinating it makes it up and then
when you write stuff into there it can
call any arbitrary function in the
driver to do anything it wants you know
so those are actually four different
categories of file system and generally
when you are telling the kernel you know
when the kernel is booting it can
extract a cpio archive into the ram FS
instance it already has and this is
called an it Rama fess the older way of
doing it before Linux implemented any
Ram based file systems it only had an it
Rd the initial Ram disk the block backed
version so it could allocate a Ram block
disk and take something like an exe to
image and copy it in there could take a
gzipped
exe to image the same way that you'd you
know you take a an ISO image for example
that you ripped from a CD and then you
can gzip it well you could you could
copy that into the the RAM disk and
mount it using the ISO 9660 driver as
the lens you look at it through and then
the third thing it can do is if you
didn't provide either of these two or if
you did provide them but it couldn't
find an init program to run out of them
in init Rama fess it looks for a file
slash ini T it
or file an it in the top-level directory
that is executed that has the executable
bit said if it can exec that it'll stop
looking further and it'll just launch
PID 1 in the in the older Ram Dass based
one it looked for a different name Linux
RC which is just historical interests
don't go there and in an it may not see
the in the Linux kernel source code in
an it may not see there's a there's a
function start kernel so if you go into
the Linux kernel source code and look in
an it slash main dot C function start
kernel you can actually trace through
how the Linux kernel starts up because
this is the one that actually does it it
has a bunch of different places it looks
as fallbacks
it looks for s been in it it looks for
etc in it it looks for been in it and if
it can't find any of those it'll it'll
launch been SH this is for the 4th -
sorry for the 3rd place it looks if
there is a root equals argument on the
command line it goes ah this is a block
device mount it and then try to find an
init program in there that used to be
you know that's that's the fallback root
filesystem so those are the three
different places that you can tell the
Linux kernel here's where to find your
root filesystem and then within that
file system you have an init program so
the kernel has finished building and at
the top level there's a file here called
VM Linux this is an elf program and I
mentioned that elf is an archive format
and you saw that abduch trick
well they do a variant of that object
trick and then stick a little header on
the front to create arch mistress boot
the file arch x86 boot BZ image and
you'll notice I mentioned that this
one's enormous we're going to go into
kernel configuration stuff after this so
what we do is we go QEMU let me see I
did a
I did a yeah so oh this little trick
here make - J dollar sign parentheses n
proc there's an N proc command that
tells you how many processors this
machine has so if you want to
automatically do SMP at the level that
this machine does you can just you know
that says run a command and turn its
output into an argument
so make - J and proc will automatically
do make - J however many processors are
in the machine that's what that little
trick does it's fun thing so we did the
make deck config we did the make and
then this is Colonel command-line which
is similar to the bare metal one qemu
system i 386 instead of armed this time
because i'm running an x86 laptop
- no graphic is the same don't pop up a
window instead give me a serial console
on standard in and standard out - no
reboot says when the system in here
tries to reboot the hardware just exit
QEMU instead rather than restarting it
here is where that kernel image we just
built lives - an it rd of a file an it
rd is as i mentioned there's the older
boot mechanism that did initial ram
disks i mentioned that you can
statically link a cpio image into the
kernel at Build time well the method of
proof having the bootloader point it at
an initial Ram disk image that usually
was a compressed block device boot
loaders still know how to do that and
the kernel still knows how to listen for
that but what it does these days is
first it checks the type to see is that
a cpio signature at the start instead of
EXT - or something like that
if ID identifies that you've fed it a
compressed cpio image it goes oh I'll
just extract this into an it Rama fess
and use an it Rama fess instead of an it
an it Rd so it can auto detect the
format so what we're doing is we're
taking that archive
feeding it in through the external an it
Rd loader and the reason we do that is
every time we change the root filesystem
we don't have to rebuild the kernel
because if it's statically linked into
the kernel we'd have to rebuild the
kernel in that slow and then the last
part which I screwed up there should not
be a space there is append this is QEMU
yz4 provide these extra arguments to the
Linux kernel command line what is the
Linux kernel command line there is a
another one of these kernel.org slash
docs slash capital D documentation is
the online place for the documentation
directory in the Linux kernel source
code under the Linux kernel source
there's capital D documentation
directory with lots and lots of files
into it I've already shown you
documentation file systems Ram FS ruda
fest and at ram FS text which is the
documentation on it Ram FS now let's
look at they moved it recently it is now
in
Oh
oh okay they moved it between 49 and 410
it's in a different place now but it's
the only old one here it moved into a
subdirectory but it's the same file name
kernel parameters is a very nice file
that just lists all the key word equals
value names that you can provide on the
on the kernel command line to tell it to
do stuff again as with the configuration
symbols there's lots and lots and lots
of them most of which aren't very
interesting the ones that you are
required to provide are well the main
one and that's wrong too if you're using
a serial console you're going to want to
say console equals the device the the
name of the serial device that you're
using you don't have to say slash dev if
you do it'll recognize it and and chop
it off but you have to identify which
serial device should the should the
serial console attach to because
otherwise you won't get any console
output and then panic equals one here
says if the kernel panics reboot after
this many seconds rather than hanging
and remember that will make QEMU exit so
that's a lot more convenient here so we
take this big invocation and we go and
this will die because on this machine I
have the root filesystem in another
place but let's just use the one that I
built a moment ago which is that root
GPIO GZ that we just did so let's go
back to here and go
rude cpio GZ and now in a moment we
should get common hello do I have a
broken QEMU on this machine
alright you're a much faster machine but
I'm gonna go back to the one that I
actually did the initial setup on cuz
this is silly oh that yes that would be
wrong
that would be why and it didn't make it
far enough to panic so it never tried to
exit
qmu system x86 64 yes that's much
happier thank you so here are you know
you'll notice there's lots and lots of
boot messages what are you doing the
clock source switched to clock source
TSA yes I saw that common you should
finish booting do I have a weird version
of QEMU on here oh yes I do Wow
it just it was booting asynchronously so
it yeah so it continued to spit console
messages after the thing so as I said
this is very simple to build and pretty
much useless we need to make the kernel
smaller we need to make user space
bigger well the next way to make user
space bigger what have I got in here is
I have a copy of busybox checked out
here and what I'm gonna do it is config
prefix I'm going to go make def config
who here has not configured a Linux
kernel okay we're going to get to
configuring the Linux kernel but busybox
actually copied kernel configuration
infrastructure so if I go make menu
config I get an interactive configurator
program where I can cursor up and cursor
down and I can hit enter to go into a
menu and I can hit space to select a
symbol or deselect a symbol or sometimes
it'll it'll cycle through asterisk m and
space where the M means build this is a
module rather than statically linking it
into the kernel and if you don't
understand what modules are just don't
use them modules are a thing you level
up to when when you need them it
basically means that after the kernel
has booted you can tell it here's an
extra chunk of code using the in Samad
or modprobe program say insert this
module into the kernel and you can also
tell it remove this module from
at which point it will hide it from you
but not free up the memory unless you've
configured the kernel in a way people
usually don't and provide an extra flag
that will from that point on mark your
kernel as tainted so that if you submit
a bug report after doing it the kernel
developers will explicitly ignore you
yeah because removing bits from a
running kernel is just not something
that can ever quite be done safely or at
least they haven't convinced themselves
that it has and they just they don't
want you to do that but people like Red
Hat with you know large amounts of money
from corporations where the system
should never be down even for
maintenance they'd love you to do that
so they'll argue with the kernel
developers but anyway this menu config
program is basically just a way of
configuring stuff and then when I'm done
do I want to save the new kernel
configuration in this case no well now
if I go to busy box and busy box make
menu config there is a similar menu
config here where you know here's stuff
that would be in the new core utils
package that was completely re
implemented you know here's you know do
you want the DOS two UNIX command do you
want the DF disk free command and they
have a whole bunch of sub things of do
you want it to have these features and
back when I was maintaining this sucker
I did a policy that there is there are a
bunch of ya make help on a lot of
packages will actually provide here's
various make targets that's a good thing
to know and you can then grep for the
ones that have config in their names def
config is the default configuration
you know you'll notice that we did the
x86 64 def config over in the kernel
land well in busybox make def config
basically says switch on everything that
is sane don't switch on the weird
debugging stuff don't switch on like the
SELinux stuff that won't build if you
don't have the right headers installed
but if it's a feature
switch it on give me a configuration
that includes pretty much everything we
know how to do so this is the big
busybox you know you can get and then
you can go into make menu config and
start switching stuff off to pare it
down there's usually two starting points
with any menu config based thing there's
all no config and all yes config all no
config is basically if you went into
menu config and switched off everything
that could be switched off this would be
your config all yes config is the
opposite switch on everything that you
can switch on and the reason that
busybox def config is different than
busybox oh yes config is that in busybox
all yes config is insane and switches on
stuff that no sane human being would
ever want and usually whatever your
system is it won't work because I
mentioned weird debugging stuff so make
def config is a good starting point so
what I did is I did make def config and
then we compile it which shouldn't take
as long as the kernel did and I don't
know if this is a release version this
is a random get snapshot but it should
still work I've built it before if
you're going to deploy it use a release
version okay and then make help grep
install which has config prefix so make
config prefix equals I can just do PWD
is an environment variable that is my
current directory slash walrus just some
name that I know isn't already there so
I told it install into a directory that
doesn't exist and so it populated this
new directory oh yes
you know my red-eye flight that I had to
get up at 3:30 a.m. for was yesterday
you'd think I'd be recovered by now
that's why I got this the drink that
chases unicorns into the ocean okay so
so this popular direct remember I said
the older Linux RC name that nobody uses
anymore well busybox has been around for
a while and it hasn't necessarily
cleaned out all of its old stuff so what
I do now is I do the same trick of find
period pipe it to cpio - HD - oh I never
remember that part
I wrote the documentation on this so I
wouldn't have to remember it yes yes yes
okay - oh all right - Oh pipe it - gzip
and route to dot CP i OG z and now what
we do is we take our earlier QEMU system
x86 64 and the cursor up and we tell it
instead go to busybox busybox route to
CPO GZ and now we add one extra little
thing Rd in it equals bin SH what I'm
saying is instead of looking for a file
called I n I T in an it Ram FS look for
this file instead as you're in it
program the name ardian it dates back to
when we were using Ram disks instead of
Ram FS but it it listens for both so
what that should say is do the same big
long overcomplicated boot
and no it didn't okay and you know what
I did wrong I didn't statically link it
all right let me explain more need more
exposition so what it did here is it
failed to boot it panicked at the end
and the okay freeing unused kernel
memory is the last thing it says before
launching an it in this case it's
freeing three different chunks failed to
execute slash bin slash Sh error
negative two error negative two in the
case of the the file is user include a
seminary care no based at H if you you
know you know that and you know int you
know negative two in this case you know
and no such file or directory
but bin SH is there yes but the dynamic
linker wasn't because I forgot to
statically link it or if it is been SH
is assembling to busy box busy box is a
file that is dynamically linked and it
is looking for the first thing it's
going to look for is this file which is
the dynamic linker that is the program
it will actually execute and then this
program will be the first argument to
that it's kind of like when I have a
shell script it has pound sign
exclamation point and a path to the
thing to actually run and then the thing
that you actually run gets this is an
argument so that Perl or Python or the
shell can interpret this script
well dynamically linked elf binary the
same way they have a dynamic linker
program that runs and then loads all
these other libraries in you know from
the library search path into memory
links all the references out of this
thing to them and then jumps to its
start and what it was basically saying
is this misleading error message that no
such file directory was saying the
dynamic linker in this thing wasn't
there all it had was a number and the
number did say what the problem was but
it didn't say what file the problem was
so if
you encounter that kind of thing you
know you you learn you learn to debug
this kind of stuff okay so what we do is
we build again and this time clean make
I don't have to do a make clean but I
don't remember the way to tell it to so
LD Flags equals - gasps static make j8
right and we build again and then when
that's done I can test that the busybox
file is statically linked while it's
doing that let me point you at a couple
other interesting web pages so yeah in
current kernels not as much in current
kernels I believe that a net Ram FS will
fall back to looking at and NIT equals
that went in like four six four seven or
something it's fairly recent within the
past year in it equals used to just tell
the colonel what in it to look for when
it was mounting a block device on you
know stage three the root equals file
back after it couldn't find a statically
linked in a tram FS and then it couldn't
find a an external Rd image so it didn't
have anything in a tram FS or in an it
Rd then the third thing it would try to
do was mount a block device and in it
equals used to only apply to that block
device you needed the other argument to
tell a net Ram FS what in it to look for
okay I think that that has recently
changed so I could say an it equals and
I'm using a fork for a9 kernels so we
might as well try let's see so that
we'll have okay so what I was pointing
to you to here let me finish the thought
I wrote a lot of documentation in that
system that I
have since stopped working on but you
know I did this one for 15 years and I
still answer questions about it but you
know Aboriginal Linux our motto was we
cross-compile so you don't have to wear
it booted this the smallest simplest
development environment capable of
rebuilding itself under from source
under self from source code and building
Linux from scratch under the result and
that meant you could natively compile
anything under qemu that you wanted to
without ever having to cross compile
again cross compiling is very hard
I wrote documentation
I meant to hand this out to the group I
wrote an intro to cross compiling that
explains you know basically what cross
compiling is and why cross compiling is
hard this is very polite because this
was written not to scare people away
from cross compiling this was sort of
you know so you have to cross compile my
sympathies here's how to do it if you
can avoid cross compiling try because
cross compiling is really really nasty
you have two contexts you have two sets
of headers you know the one for the
system that you're building on and the
one that your system for the system
you're building for you have two sets of
libraries you're linking in against one
for the system you're building on one
for the system you're building for most
systems go configure make make install
and you know configure asks questions
about the system you're building on and
uses them to you know apply to the
system you're building for and when
they're two different systems the whole
of configure is asking the wrong
questions you know about half of
cross-compiling is figuring out how to
lie to otto conf or to just get it to
stop because it's like well let me build
a little test binary and run it to see
what the out what output it produces
well you can't when you're across
compiling it won't run on this system
that's sort of the point of cross
compiling and your build system if you
are building something locally that like
generates a
you know a lot of times you will run a
small C program to produce code that
that or modify code that then gets
compiled so you need a native compiler
you need what's called a host compiler
and you need a target compiler to build
for the target and so you have to
separate contexts and have to keep them
separate you have to prevent bits of
your host system from leaking into your
target system and what you wind up doing
is you know just natively compiling on a
bunch of different targets it's like I
tested it on an arm I tested it on spark
I tested it on PowerPC I found slightly
different bugs in each case but that's
okay there's a linear number of them
well when you're cross compiling I
tested cross compiling from this system
to that system and I got slightly
different bugs every from system so it's
hosts x targets so you're testing you
know attack surface is just
exponentially larger and then there's
the fact that only about 2% of the
developers will ever care about cross
compiling at all you know Debian has
over 40,000 packages in its repository
maybe a thousand of them have ever been
cross compiled on a good day with a
tailwind and so it's just cross
compiling is a thing that can be done
but the point of this entire project was
native compiling under emulation is so
much easier and then the trick I did was
I fired up a dist CC and taught it to
call out through through qem use
emulated network to the cross compiler
running on the host so configure ran
fine the you know there was one set of
headers the header information was pre
processed before DCC sends it out to the
compile node linking ran fine because
that happened inside the emulator I
could install the result into the system
so that it might dependency recognition
you know worked fine but the heavy
lifting of compilation was moved outside
of the emulator to someplace that CPU
was cheap and I had access to SMP you
know so that was a that was a
thing I did it for a long time and it's
sort of out of scope of here but feel
free to read about it what I am actually
working on now is a project called make
root which basically one of the things I
virginal Linux did is it built its own
cross tool chain and its own native tool
chain well there's a project out there
now called muscle cross make by the guy
who does muscle Lib C rich Felker which
is a tool chain builder that not only
creates cross compilers but creates
native compilers which is the thing that
I couldn't beat out of you know build
root will create cross compilers it
doesn't want to create native compilers
cross tool ng it'll create cross
compilers it doesn't want to create
native compilers you know code sorcery
would give you cross compilers they
wouldn't give you native hose or a bunch
of places they gave cross compilers from
but if I then wanted to build stuff in
the resulting system I didn't have a
compiler I could install into the thing
I could fish them out of Debian
Debian has native compilers for all the
targets it supports but they depend on
Debian they're dynamically linked not
statically linked so I would need G Lib
C installed for like super H and stuff
like that and it's like yeah well now I
have I have a package that will actually
give me the native compilers which is
why I started over and I went I can be
much much simpler about building a thing
and what this is is this is a shell
script that builds a root filesystem
which I'll go through this in a little
bit after after I go through configuring
your kernel I'll go through this as
here's how you make a simpler root
filesystem but it's it's a shell script
that will basically populate one of
these directories you then cpio up and
then run it out of an it Rama fess and
that gives you a nice starting system
once you have one of these things if you
want to repackage it as ext2 or
repackage it as squash FS there's a make
squash FS utility you can read the man
page up I can walk you through how to do
that to basically creating a file system
for one of the other file formats is
either run a utility like make squash FS
or Jenny XT two FS that
works like tar does here's a directory
here's the output file it just puts it
into the thing or what you can do is you
can use a loopback device anybody here
not know about loopback devices okay
loopback devices if you need to create a
block device file system you have to do
it as route you can let's see D Dei F
equals dev 0 Oh F equals blah MGBs
equal block size equals 1 Meg count
equals let's say 256 so let's create a
256 megabytes and
have to care so that created a 256
megabytes IMG and then I can format it
yes we come on come there we go and then
I can go mount - Oh loop blah IMG need
to create a directory for it mount - Oh
loop blah IMG sub der and then
there we go and sub derp is that
filesystem a a loopback device is a
special block device that creates it
basically is it's another type of lens
remember how I said ext2 is a lens you
look at a block device through to make
it look you know like a directory full
of files
well this driver lets you look at a file
and make it look like a block device it
shows up as dev loop 0 or dev loop 1
there's a bunch of them you know these
days it dynamically creates more there
used to be a static link number of them
kind of like PT wise you know they're
dynamically allocated now they used to
be statically allocated they split the
difference by statically allocating the
first few and then dynamically adding
more as you asked for them and what you
can actually do is you can do ello set
up dev loop 0 which I believe by default
will tell you what it's associated with
you know so if I say dev loop 1 it says
it's not associated with anything but
dev loop 0 is associated with this thing
if what the mount command is doing
behind the scenes is calling ello setup
to associate file name with loop device
there's a man page on ello setup if you
want to know and then when you unmount
it the unmount command recognizes oh
this is a look this is a loopback device
and calls ello setup - D - D associate
that loopback device with that file and
the advantage of this is I can
[Music]
is I can copy a file into here that's to
text into subtor and then I can unmount
subterra and then I can gzip bla IMG and
I I have just created a compressed ext2
image of 256 megabytes size that's the
basic procedure for if I want to create
block device images now this works for
normal block devices it doesn't work for
flash devices flash devices aren't
exactly block devices because the way
flash works normal block devices have a
granularity of like 512 bytes or these
days 4k and the file systems have a
block size of like 4k this is the the
size that they upgrade with if your
underlying device has a has an upgrade
update granularity larger than the block
size of a file system bad things happen
because if your Flash every time you
write to the flash is updating 128 K
chunk and you think you're writing 4k
sectors so you have ext3 journaling and
it's like right we write these things
into the journal and then we update just
this sector and we haven't written
anything before it and we haven't
written anything after it so we don't
need to keep track of that and if we
lose power in the middle of it all we
have to do is replay the journal and
that'll tell us you know what what
changes we were in the middle of and
then when we try to remount it oh the
entire directory is gone because that 4k
was in the middle of 128 K of directory
and all of it got zeroed and then didn't
get written back because the power was
interrupted and oops my flash file
system is corrupted because I'm using a
file system type that isn't aware of
Flash's erase granularity this happens
it's a bad thing so they have what's
called log structured file systems that
are designed for use on flash that the
first thing they do is they do a special
IO control against the block device
that says what is your block you what is
your erase granularity what is the
update size and alignment and stuff
where are your erase blocks so that
every time I update I am updating an
entire erase block and they do things
like they pack the data into the erase
block so that they're not doing extra
writes to you know we only update it a
little of this thing so we don't want to
erase and rewrite the whole thing we
want to save our rights and and you know
round-robin around the disk because
that's better for flash because flash
wears out you know so they they work in
a completely different way and if you
try to mount one on a normal block
device or on a loopback device it goes I
can't figure out what the erase block
size is that's part of the format of the
file system I fail and it refuses to
mount so if you mount one of those you
have to provide if you're faking it on
something like a block device these days
I believe you can provide an extra - OH
option - to tell the driver and pretend
your erase block size is this size so I
can make a flash file system that I can
then copy into flash but that's a whole
area you now know you need to look it up
but I can't cover it in any reasonable
detail here okay so meanwhile going back
to here we have built
I opened a lot of windows didn't I I
wonder which one is ok here we go so did
I install no I didn't
so make I should still have it up here
make there we go
oh did you have a question okay so we
install into the thing now we and it's
the same thing except
statically linked know dynamically
linked darn it
it should have installed over it anyway
you want try that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I didn't actually do a
make clean this time did you detect that
I changed the see flags and you're
rebuilding everything okay
statically linked whoo all right let's
do that install again
what are you compiling I just built oh
you gonna rebuild the thing and I didn't
to do the see flags here hmm I note that
I haven't maintained this project since
2006 you can blame me for this but I
will complain all right so file want to
spin busybox static whoo and let's do
the cpio thing again which should still
be in the command history and now let us
go to where ever had that kernel launch
invocation too many open windows here we
go
and let's try it now hey all right
I have a shell prompt so I have now made
a simple to make kernel and root
filesystem the kernel is still six and a
half Meg's containing as you saw from
the boot messages lots and lots of stuff
we don't need and the root filesystem
still has rather a lot of stuff we don't
need it's the biggest busy box you can
make and also you know I well it doesn't
have a it doesn't have an init script so
I have to mount T proc proc make dere
proc I didn't make the directories and
then I should be able to if config and
you know nothing set up the network you
know
we need an init script that actually
does some stuff so actually I'll get to
the current let me go to the root
filesystem stuff first this is that root
filesystem builder I talked about so let
me walk you through what it does you can
you know github.com slash land Lee slash
make root there's one script make root
where you can basically just let me see
if I let me check out a fresh copy of it
no no just do I have no I do not have it
extensively locally modified here woot
January 31st is that current let me see
yes okay so the first thing it's
building is when I left busybox I
started over from scratch in a project
called toy box because I felt I could do
a better job
toy box is now the standard command line
of Android I am attempting to turn
android into a self-hosting development
environment I'm using what I learned on
Aboriginal Linux to basically make it so
that what's installed by default on
Android should be enough to build a OSP
let alone Linux from scratch so that
having an Android phone is sufficient to
develop for Android it's got USB on the
end of it if you plug it into a USB hub
you can add a USB keyboard USB mouse use
chromecast to put it on a big screen and
you know this is a gigahertz processor
with at least half a gig of ram you know
it it's a reasonably powerful system and
if you plug it into USB it's gonna be
charging itself so I gave a talk about
that here at 2013 the Android guys went
basically sure why not and started
merging my stuff and that's taking up an
awful lot of my time now what I didn't
do is I didn't tell it to use the
current version of toy box but I'll just
grab the
one of the things I did is I made it so
that if you if you have an extracted
directory in the packages directory with
the same name it'll use that instead of
extracting the tarball you know 300
something line script but it actually
does a lot so let me walk you through it
so it's building toy box instead of busy
box because I am migrating all my own
stuff from busy box to toy box it it's a
somewhat cleaner implementation if you
saw the the talk a couple of sessions
ago on on shrinking the Linux kernel he
he was comparing toy box to busy box the
the really fundamental difference the
reason that Android can use it and
couldn't use busy box even though busy
box predates ant you know busy box is
older than Android and you know you're
not gonna wait for them to start
shipping it it's there they're not
shipping it for a reason is that they
have a no GPL in user space policy gplv3
happened about the same time that
Android did and they responded by
throwing out the GPL v2 baby with the
GPL v3 bathwater you know now that now
that there's no such thing as the GPL
anymore and you have warring camps that
can't you know the Linux kernel and
samba can't share code even though they
implement two ends of the same protocol
and each has to police their key their
submissions to make sure that they
didn't get code from the other one
because that would be incompatible and
they get sued it's like android just
went nope
opting out and you know they rewrote
they rewrote their Bluetooth daemon they
threw away the one they had that was GPL
and wrote one that's Apache License
they're they're slowly going through and
removing that so toy box is under a
public domain equivalent license that
looks like a BSD license to make the
lawyers happy and you know that's why
they can merge it okay so I did just
build the thing and what that did is
that created a directory called route
that has a bunch of stuff and in the
build directory it created a route GPIO
GZ and this is a mix of toy box and busy
box you could use just busy box but as I
said my own personal
development I am migrating from one to
the other I'm only using busybox for the
commands I haven't implemented a good
enough version of in toybox yet so
walking you through what this does this
is the script on github it starts if you
you know if you don't run it with any if
you run it with unknown commands it
prints out a health message it figures
out if you've set the environment
variable cross compile if so that is
what cross compiler to use that says I'm
not building it for the the host system
I'm building it for arm or PowerPC or
whatever the cross compiler is so it you
know figures out a couple of things from
that and it makes sure that it can
actually run the cross compiler because
if you pointed it across compile you
know compiler that isn't in your path
and go uh no those directory names I
mentioned above you can you can replace
them if you want to it checks to make
sure that you can build static binaries
because it turns out on things like
fedora unless you install the package
that contains Lib ca it doesn't install
the static libraries by default so you
have to install an extra package in
order to be able to link stuff that
statically it when you install the tool
chain it can only do stuff dynamically
because Ullrich dreper hated static
linking and even though he left to go
work at the bank at evil goldman sachs
they haven't undone all of the damage
static linking is very useful you'll
you'll notice I I hadn't copied the
shared libraries into the root
filesystem I could run the L DD command
to see what shared libraries do I need
and copy them and then remember to run l
DD against those libraries because
libraries can link against other
libraries but that's that's a lot of
work up to that the simplest Linux
system as it says in the title of the
presentation is not going to be
dynamically linked because dynamically
dynamic linking adds complexity
statically linking dynamic linking is
worth it once you have reached enough
different files sharing the same
libraries
you're saving enough memory to care and
it that won't be for a while
okay so this is a thing that basically
just extracts a tarball
into a working directory and it checks
to see if there is an extracted version
and it will use that instead it's only a
few lines you can read that you know so
and then clean up is the one that
deletes it afterwards this is basically
tar extract and this is RM dash RF only
they're you know kind of fancy versions
but every time you see that one of them
is tar extract this does a double you
get of the source tar balls from this
URL and checks the sha-1 sum so these
are the toy box and busy box packages we
will be building and then the first
thing it does is it sees if there's an
airlock directory that contains the toy
box binary because I mentioned that when
you are cross compiling it's easy for
bits of the host system to leak into the
target system and you have that
combinatorial problem where it built
slightly different on Ubuntu than it did
on RedHat that it did on this thing and
instead of one set of things to test
it's one for each target so it's number
of hosts times number of targets and
that is going to get out of hand and you
will have stuff that you haven't tested
well the way I solve that is I spent
years making sure that busybox
provided tools you could build a whole
system with and these days I'm doing the
same with toybox every tool that is in
toy box def config is good enough to
build a system with not all the tools
are there but you know the ones that are
there my said can actually run auto con
for that kind of thing so what I do is I
build toy box install it into a
directory and then I have a list of
files I need to copy out of the host
system because toybox doesn't implement
a reasonable version and then and there
will always be a few because I don't
include a compiler so I'm copying the
GCC I'm sim linking to the host GCC I'm
sim linking to the host bin utils in
this directory of commands and then I
set the path to just that directory
and this is called the airlock step
where once I've done this I'm using this
little tiny system I built to provide an
own build environment to isolate against
variations in the host system now
Aboriginal Linux was doing a whole lot
more sanitization it had a whitelist of
environment variables where if it wasn't
one of these recognized environment
variables that would unset it and it was
doing a lot more cleansing and stuff and
95% of the time you don't need to worry
about that so this is you know this is a
little more than the 80/20 thing this is
like the 90% that gets you 95% of the
thing so I this is creating an airlock
step which is strictly speaking optional
but it means that I'm building in an own
environment I then this is basically
just dependency checking because you
know in case I don't need to rebuild
stuff that skip that stuff then what
this does is this creates the directory
layout this is doing a make dere of all
the standard directories in one line
this is pretty much the directories that
packages expect to be in and with this
set of directories I can install all the
Linux from scratch packages Linux from
scratch is an online book that tells you
how to create a very large very
complicated about a hundred and ten
megabyte system using conventional new
packages but it's the base of most OS
versions
it's nothing remotely like the embedded
world uses and I as I said I spent many
years making it so that a megabyte and
change of busybox could replace a
hundred megabytes of canoe packages but
that is the old reference build that I
use because you know if you want to use
the big version of said you can mine
should be a drop-in replacement for it
but in order to ensure that it's a
drop-in replacement I need to test
against the old one and I need to test
it can build the old one in case I am
missing anything so you know there's an
etc directory a TMP
Proc sis dev home M&T root and then
under user there's been s bin and Lib
and then there's a directory there and
these are pretty much the directories
that Linux expects to be there there is
a standard called the Linux standard
base LSB that unfortunately the Linux
Foundation took it over the Linux
Foundation was formed when the went to
black holes of bureaucracy combined to
form Voltron of bureaucracy and one of
those was the free standards group the
other one was OS DL and when they
combined the the focus shifted from
maintaining this standard to asking
donors for money and unfortunately what
this meant is that the Linux standard
base was so badly maintained that a year
or so back Debian when the 5.0 release
came out threw up its hands and said
we're done we're not paying any
attention to the standard anymore which
is kind of sad because there should be a
standard for this stuff so there's still
four point 1 LSB for point one and it
does describe the layout of these things
etc directory is where a bunch of config
files traditionally live temp was the
directory that UNIX used for temporary
files proc is where you mount proc FS
sis is where you mount sisyphus those
are two synthetic file systems that let
you give you an API to play with the
kernel so that PS can see what processes
are available and you know insmod can
see what hardware is available and stuff
like that dev is the directory that the
device nodes go in I mentioned that the
the serial console device is one of the
devices in dev dev Velo set up sorry dev
loop 0 when I was showing loopback
devices home is the directory under
which the user accounts live MNT is a
directory for additional mounts that's
the traditional name for it the new
modern systems added one called media
that does the same thing but they liked
it Roo
is the home directory of the root user
this is fallout from the days when home
used to be on its own partition a lot
and in case you hadn't you know in case
if you ever trashed that partition it
would give the and add a login as root
to administer the system it would give
the root user you know somewhere to have
his files user bin s bin and Lib
actually exists because Ken Thompson and
Dennis Ritchie on their original pdp-11
in 1971 filled up their first disk their
their root disk was a half megabyte very
fast disk and then they had what was
called an RKO five disk pack which was
two and a half megabytes of external
space basically like a USB disk today
slower but much larger and when they
filled up their their root partition
they leaked it into the user directory
where they had the user accounts and
then when they got a second expansion
disk they moved all the user accounts to
the new disk and they called that one
home and they left the user directory to
be eaten by the operating system and
then people retconned all sorts of
rationales for this but no that's why it
happened and these days when I'm making
a system you'll notice I just symlink
user bin to bin user s bin to s bin and
user Lib to Lib so you know there's
there's there's a bin an Espeon and a
Lib at the top directory that I just
symlink to the second copy of them
collapsing together because I don't care
it doesn't matter you know but I
researched why they did this in the
first place and Dennis Ritchie wrote it
up as a historical anecdote and I went
oh that's why they did it now I know
that we don't need to do it anymore
a lot of this researching why we do
things in the first place if you drill
down into it a lot of times you can
figure out it's okay to do it
differently and it's okay not to do it
at all once you understand why it was
there so that's an example of that and
then the very direct eree was it was a
place to put things that should persist
across reboots but should be writable
because etc could be in a read-only
directory you know so config files
versus dynamic config files so those are
basically the the directories it expects
to be there and you can just copy this
snippet right out of my thing or just
run this file then I create an init
program now you'll notice I said you
know an it is PID 1 it is the program
you run when the system first comes up
and I actually wrote up a little things
I probably won't have time to cover but
should ok so an it is weird and I wrote
down why and yeah these are a bunch of
different examples of types of an it you
may encounter using bin SH a--'s in it
you've seen me do that your app the
hello world was an example of that but a
lot of internet of things think we'll
just run an you know there an it is PID
one here is a shell script running as an
it and then at the end it execs another
program I wrote one called one it
there's system 5 in it which was the
conventional and everybody was using 10
years ago then Android uses its own init
program these days there's a horrible
one called system D and then there's
others like upstart and open our C when
people were trying to move beyond the
the main problem with system 5 in it is
it predated the widespread use of SMP so
it brought the system up in a
single-threaded manner and people wanted
to paralyze paralyzed the in it to bring
it up to bring the system up faster and
they couldn't quite agree on that
because you know well this has to come
up after the network interface comes up
so suddenly we have a dependency
resolver where everything has to know
what else it depends on and people wrote
up a lot of different things and Red Hat
basically shouted everybody down by
having more money okay so PID one the
first process that Linux launches is
special and what's special about it is
to start
with it has no parent it is launched
directly by the kernel if it ever exits
the kernel will panic
you saw that kernel panic earlier of you
know we couldn't find in it because it
was dying where we couldn't run in it
because it was dynamically linked so we
got a panic message and then QEMU exited
and otherwise would have rebooted the
system because in it should never exit
and it has most signals blocked
specifically the way they implement that
not exactly but you can think of it as
sig default is sig ignore for an it
where if you get a signal
the default handler for it will ignore
it rather than killing the program and
if a program's parent process dies so
that you have an orphaned child that
when it exit it wants to send sig to
somebody to notify it of its exit code
but its parent has gone away it will be
repented to in it and it is the Reaper
of orphan children okay so and it does a
lot of things if you run an it equal
slash bin slash SH your system will
accumulate zombies if your shell does
not know to listen for sig tiled which
most of them don't there is actually a
workaround if you set sig child to sig
ignore in the signal handler tell it you
know instead of having a signal handler
just said it to sig ignore sig child
will be delivered and the fact that it
was ignored is fine and then the child
can exit so when you are running an init
program if you're not gonna handle sig
child set the signal handler to sig
ignore and you have you have to actually
do that explicitly because the default
one being like sig ignore isn't good
enough in that case so yeah and another
thing is for example an it can't reboot
the system because the reboot system
call exits your process so the kernel
will panic before rebooting so you have
to fork a child have it
call reboot and then you hang and wait
yes I I mentioned that I wrote one it
one it is a tiny little init program
it's in toy box you can find it on the
busy box mailing list way back when but
they didn't merge it where it does just
the basic setup another thing about an
it is that it inherits file handle zero
file handle one file handle to pointing
to dev console it starts with a standard
in standard out in standard error
pointing to whichever dev console you
had on in it Rama fess if you didn't
have an init Ram FS or if you created an
init Rama fess but didn't add a dev
console to it which you'll notice we
haven't in any of the ones we've done so
far
those opens will fail and your standard
in standard out and standard error of an
it will be closed meaning anything you
write will be ignored and if you try to
do that as a shell prompt you know if
you try to then exec bin SH it will exit
immediately because it has no input to
read from and no output to write to and
it basically gets a sig type and goes
nope so what this init script does this
init script you know we start with pound
sign exclamation point been SH we then
set a home directory and set a path
because we didn't necessarily inherit
one our environment is mostly blank so
if we want you know some basic
environment variables that you just sort
of expect to be there we have to set
them ourselves we mount proc on proc we
mount Sisyphus on sis the reason that
it's doing this is I sometimes use a
Senate script to change route into a
directory and when you change route into
a directory the system may already have
some stuff there so that's why I'm
checking if they're already mounted is
just for change route it won't be in
your systems I then mount dev temp FS
dev temp FS is a file system that was
added a few years ago that automatically
populates the dev directory with all the
devices that are there so you don't need
something like you dev or system system
D to do it you don't need a daemon
listening for hot plug events in
creating device
the colonel can do it for you and it
took several years to browbeat Gregg
Crowe Hartman and company into going you
know the colonel can really do this for
you but what names will be used okay you
notice how under sis FS sis class like
you know mem there are names why don't
you use these names and eventually they
went on I will use those names they are
unique and it's like yeah so you know
you you get a set of devices from depth
ffs and then dev pts is the pseudo
terminals if you use the new PTY format
that auto you know that automatically
allocates them rather than the
statically linked front ones from way
back one that requires a file system to
you know every time you create one it
shows up in this directory so that's
where it expects it so yeah that that
does amount of dev pts amount of dev
temp FS amount of sisyphus and amount of
proc it then does an if config of e0 and
a route edie default gateway for QEMU if
you are using qem use emulated network
this is the address that if you ran dhcp
this is the address it would give you
and this is the gateway that will talk
to the outside world through it's
basically faked IP masquerading that it
does and then i attempt to set the the
date in case I am emulating a system
that doesn't have a persistent clock
because you know some are more SH boards
or stuff like that it's like this system
doesn't have a clock so the kernel
doesn't know what to set the clock to so
I can do it once I brought up the
virtual network I can do a transaction
with a host it says hey what time is it
and get that set up I then figure out
when I you know the kernel command line
is available I think this is actually
the
yeah this is the colonel I just built so
this is the emulated system actually
that is still running under QEMU but and
proc command line this is the command
line that I fed in you may remember that
from the QEMU command line so in proc if
s I can see what my command line is and
what I did here was I ran said against
proc CMD line to see if there's a
command line argument if so I figure out
what device it is and the reason I do
that is remember that standard in
standard out in standard error that init
inherited go to slash dev slash console
well dev console is a device that is an
alias for whatever actual console device
you're using to talk to the outside
world but it does not provide a
controlling TTY so if I hit control C it
doesn't send a signal to my program and
if I accidentally if I run like ping
that just endlessly ping stuff and
doesn't exit and I'm going control C
control C control C and it's ignoring me
and I'm going right after reboot my
emulator because I screwed up you know
well what one it does is it closes the
standard end standard out and standard
error that it inherited and opens the
ones from the actual console device the
serial device that does provide a
controlling TTY so that if I'm connected
to that one and I hit control C it sends
the program a signal okay so that's why
I'm doing that thing with the console
you don't necessarily have to do that in
your thing if you don't expect to have a
command line running as PID one you know
you're in it will also do the proper
setup to that thing if you run sis 5 in
it or something like that but I'm doing
that here because trying to be simple
and then I figure out you know okay what
program do I run next by default I just
run bin SH but I can set the environment
variable handoff in all caps one fun
little thing about mmm-hmm
one fun little thing about this is
let's see
huh any unrecognized keyword equals
value argument on the kernel command
line it will set as an environment
variable so I can set any environment
variable I want to tell my init script
to do stuff on the QEMU command line so
that's you know just a fun little thing
now notice I had to put that before the
Rd Annett line because an it equals our
Rd in it equals it will think that it's
an argument to SH okay one once you get
to that point everything else becomes an
argument to SH so it would have to it
does have a positioning dependency
alright so getting back to this script
so I create my init script and here is
the EOF of the here document if you know
shell programming I just wrote this out
as a here document so that the contents
of the script could be in the in the
script and then I change mod plus exit
because if it can't execute the init it
won't run and you can't run a shell
script unless it has the executable bit
set I then write out an acceptor
password file to say these are the two
users that are on the system and this is
in the format that etc password has been
in forever and I write out an etc group
file I did not write out shadow files so
there's no passwords associated with
this I can't login as any of these users
but su if you're switching user from
root doesn't care and you know I could
have set up a shadow thing but then what
passwords what I assigning to them it's
like I just didn't bother but this lets
me this lets them know UID 0 is root you
know which UID 0 is always root but this
lets it know that the name root goes
with that and if I log in as root my
default shell should be been SH and my
home directory should be here and then I
created a guest account to be UID 500
and I told it you know here's your home
directory here's the shell to run that's
just what the acceptor password format
is there's a I think there's a man page
on it and then I wrote name server 8.88
to 8 into etc resolve com
the file slash etc slash resolved
confiar that the c library reads every
time you attempt to do a DNS lookup it
goes where are my name servers 8.8.8.8
is the IP of the google dns pool so i
don't actually have to even put in a
second one you're supposed to have full
back servers but like that's a pool of
30-something machines around the world
that it does the automatic magic routing
to the closest one to the through the
weird backbone stuff and that basically
means that should all if i can get out
to the net
that's the dns server that should be up
barring nuclear war and even then maybe
so then you know i so those were
actually the directories i created and
the the configuration files i added to
give me a basic system we're playing
around on a shell prompt if I do LS dash
L it should give me like usernames for
the files at least the ones belonging to
root and group sort of thing then I
build an install toy box which you know
it it's only this and the only reason
it's it's weird is you know I I did a
make you know set up for is the thing
that's basic Atari extract to the
tarball make def config just like
busybox
I then changed one of the symbols
because the muscle Lib C maintainer and
I have this long-standing disagreement
about how no mmm you should be
configured if you're not using a no
immune system this does not apply to you
at all and I've actually updated that
but I haven't pushed it to the
repository yet so it only does it for no
menu systems if you care about knowing
them you stay after we don't have time
but I've done a lot with them I
mentioned that elf is essentially an
archive format for binary data well
there's a slightly upgraded version
called FD pick that annotates it with
slightly more data and the reason for
this is no MMU systems can't have two
processes using the same address space
to see diff
things because it doesn't have a memory
management unit II can't remap them it
can sometimes have you know low water
marks and high water marks where if you
access memory outside of this window
you'll get a seg fault but if you can
access that address you see the same
thing for every process meaning if your
elf thing wants to be loaded at address
hex 1000 and you have two instances of
it running you can't because the second
instance would need to load at the same
address as the first instance and they
would get sad and the way most elf
programs are linked the you know there's
like four interesting segments there's
the code segment the data segment the
BSS and the other one I'll think about
it as soon as I stop trying but the the
problem is they're all put right after
each other in memory and the addresses
of them you know this piece of machine
code will go where I am or the start of
this you know the start of the program
plus this many bytes for the data or for
BSS is the RO data is the other one
there's one code segment and three data
segments basically one of the data
segments is for data that you can that
starts initialize to a value but the you
can modify it afterwards it's basically
your global variables that are
initialized to a value BSS is for your
global variables that are initialized to
zero so their contents don't actually
have to be as stored any elf thing it
basically M Maps a segment of memory
there that isn't backed by the file and
then goes you know have at and then the
RO data is the stuff that's initialized
to a value but then if you try to write
to it you will get a seg fault because
it is not writable you know and they're
basically all glued together in elf as
one big contiguous chunk of memory
what FD pic does is it says these are
now for conferred distinct chunks of
memory load them wherever you can fit
and that means you can share the code
segment with other programs that think
they've you know loaded this and it they
also it's a pic position independent
normally we only link libraries that way
where we say we have saved in a register
or saved in some global thing that you
know either ties up a register or cause
us an extra indirect you know load to
slow your assembly down but that means
that wherever you know it can be loaded
at different starting addresses and that
means if you have shared libraries well
each shared library doesn't magically
know what all the other shared libraries
you have running are so they can't at
compile time pick a unique memory
location to be so they have to be
relocatable because they could be used
in combination with who knows what other
libraries well what they did is pi
position independent executables are
executables built as pic so that they
can be relocated and the security guys
love this because that way if you try to
exploit it using an absolute address and
it's loaded at a random location each
time you load it's harder to exploit
well then Noah mem you guys love this
because it's like I can have three
instance of this loaded at different
locations and they don't you know it's
not going to conflict with other
programs that think they're using the
same thing but what FD pick lets you do
is it lets you say okay the read only
section can be shared with other
instances of the program the code
section can be shared with other
instances of the program the data
section and BSS you need your own
instances of because you're gonna write
to that data so these two are shared
wherever they can fit these two are
unique wherever they can fit however if
your memory is fragmented you can't use
the MMU to collate it but you can fit it
into smaller chunks because we've broken
the program into four different pieces
that can load wherever you can fit them
FD pick is much much nicer for Noah menu
systems but it means you need a
different kind of program loader you
know so it when you build the program
you need to produce a different output
format so again went off on a tangent
but anyway that me arguing with the
muscle Lib C maintainer so anyway it
does a build statically linking and
it doesn't install and then clean up is
that our M dash RF thing and then this
is a busy box install where I did
something called mini config and the the
last little bit I'm gonna get to and I
think I'm going overtime probably but
the last little bit I'm gonna get to is
configuring you know drilling down into
the kernel config this is the same
format as the kernel config what I did
is instead of a def config busybox
i told it these are the symbols I want
only these symbols start with all no
config and there's there's a bunch of
them you know but you know this is less
than a hundred symbols and busybox has
hundreds and hundreds of symbols a full
config file for busybox which I just
built
is 1097 lines this is it ends on line
261 and it started on line 191 so 150
symbols instead of a thousand and stuff
and that's for selecting you know rather
a lot of stuff and what this is this is
a format called mini config which I did
write up documentation on ones
I tried to send this upstream to the
colonel of documentation on how to do it
you'll notice this was 2005 I
resubmitted it again a year later to see
if they changed their minds and like no
bunch of people are using this
documentation on it is not submitted
upstream to the colonel if you ever
think about Linux kernel stuff oh well
any interesting idea immediately gets
implemented and done by the vast hordes
of kernel developers I will point you at
the fact that the squash FS developer
the squash FS developers spent something
like seven years attempting to merge
squash FS into the kernel he took a year
off to full-time push it upstream into
the kernel after it was already in Red
Hat SUSE Debbie and Gen 2 and like
everything else it had been merged
everywhere and the kernel developers
wouldn't take it
I spent something like seven years
getting Perl removed from the kernel
build environment from the first Oh
wouldn't it be a good idea to use temp
FS for an it Ram FS from me first
mentioning out of the mailing list of
you knows anybody working on this to me
actually sitting down and doing it was
something like nine years okay so yeah
the the the normal state of things is
for somebody to do it off in a corner
and then it's abandoned and it never
goes upstream into the kernel if you
know browbeating all these developers
for you know oh you implemented stuff
for your company and you've been using
it in-house for years but it is an
upstream you know the Cardle that's
actually fairly normal it's sad but it's
normal so before that tangent I was
attempting to explain Oh what was I
attempting to explain I closed the
window oh I was never displaying mini
config
where I did
I actually did documentation describing
you know all sorts of stuff about mini
config but I will walk you through it
right now basically what you do is you
have key word equals value config
symbols like this in the same format
they appear in the config file but the
question you ask yourself is if I start
with make all no config in the Linux
kernel and busybox and anything that's
using menu config and I go okay I've
switched everything off now I want to
pull up that menu config tool and I have
a checklist written down of look for
this symbol and switch it on and every
time I do so there's a dependency
resolver that may switch on other
symbols for me or change their values or
whatever
well that runs every time I poke a
symbol and menu config switch it on or
switch it off it may have fallout with
other symbols in the kernel but I don't
really care all I care about is I
started with all no config and then I
went down my checklist switching on
these symbols and then I saved the
result and I built it I know how to do
that by hand can I oughta mate this
process and yes you can that's exactly
what mini config does and the magic line
here is make all no config Kay config
underscore all config equals the name of
the file containing all these symbols
it's a horrible name a large part of
what that patch I had from many years
ago was having a make mini config target
that among other things would tell you
if you tried to set a symbol that didn't
exist instead of silently ignoring it it
would go oops
error you screwed up you know that kind
of thing and there was bike shedding
from a guy named Roman Zippo and even
though he's not there anymore it's I did
tangent tangent so this is a fairly
useful technique for configuring busybox
a lot more you know concisely and it
used al dila oh it said it as an
environment variable not on the command
line make is terrible
I'm sorry it people give Python guff
about the significant whitespace and
totally ignore the fact that make
requires tabs not spaces in a lot of
places like you know it it combines
imperative and declarative code in the
same context where you have to care what
order things happen in but have no
control over it it's like no tangent
there's a whole rant on there yeah
configure make and make install all kind
of need to be replaced it's just nobody
can really agree on what I already went
into the whole Auto conf is you know
totally does not work with cross
compiling and half the things that's
checking for specified by POSIX anyway
and if your build environment isn't
POSIX fix your build environment and
make install of course has no idea what
a package manager is so things anyway
but meanwhile we do configure make and
make install and configure if X just
tells it where to install and I'm
installing the unstriped version in case
I want to you know run gdb against or
something and then this was my attempt
to copy the dynamic libraries out of the
cross compiler on to the system to give
the option of dynamically linking and
just ignore this entire section because
it doesn't work you can actually see
that it's my second attempt and the
problem is I can get it easily to work
with any one cross compiler getting it
to work with all cross compilers which
may be using different C libraries
there's a lot of testing there it's on
my to-do list so just ignore the thing
about try to make that work and then if
I want to build additional packages you
know I have a second example here that
you know what if I want to cross compile
more stuff well here's cross compiling
you know Z Lib and drop bear and
installing those into the system here's
just examples of using the same
infrastructure to do that with different
packages in case you want to cross
compile more stuff and then at the very
end you may have noticed I kept pulling
up this file to look at the end where
it's like and here's the invocation to
turn that into a
cpio GZ file you know so that is what
this build script does and if you feed
it one of the muscle cross make tool
chains which I've been talking to rich
Felker he and I actually work together
to try to get him to do binary releases
so I could just point you at a URL of
download the binary of the pre-built
tool chain extract it add it to your
path and then follow along building the
thing and it's not up yet because he's
been really really busy and I'm not
hosting it anywhere because it's gplv3
and I don't want to get any of that on
me I launched the first GPL enforcement
suits that actually wound up in court
suing people back when I was busy box
maintainer I know a whole lot more about
GPL enforcement than any sane person
would ever want to and after a year of
empirically going through and proving
that none of these companies that were
shipping busybox binaries had any code
we wanted not adding one line of code to
the busybox repository after looking at
a whole bunch of source tree dumps i
basically went uh I don't want to go
there and I really don't but but it made
me a lot more careful about license
compliance stuff because you can't you
can't spend a whole lot of time dealing
with legal stuff without being really
careful to make sure you don't have to
again okay so that is an example of
building a simple root filesystem but
building a simple kernel def config was
terrible so let's walk through real
quick because we're short on time let's
walk through kernel building so I
actually I showed you the start of this
this file before CI configure creates a
config file I haven't really had time to
talk about device trees but when the
kernel boots
the bootloader there's actually two
bootloader stages on real Hardware you
have a bootloader stage one that does
two minutes lovely okay
ask me afterwards the the real hardware
does things that qmu doesn't have to so
q is a built-in bootloader we've just
been using that and wait it out so so we
start with all no config and in order to
do a standard x86 system these are in
theory the three symbols you need what
board am i using and where is my serial
console so I set these three symbols I
then do the make I then boot it and I
get no output and the reason I get no
output is that printf is switched off
why is printf switched off because the
symbol config embedded was broken by him
by this commit which was really stupid
special case nonsense that that says
when all no config happens switch this
symbol on which results in opening a
menu so that a lot more symbols can be
switched off and this this winds up
switching off printf so what you
actually do is you do a special commit
so you have a line that looks like this
config embedded is not set which
ordinarily in which is how you tell dot
config a symbol is switched off yes
pound sign means a comment but this
special comment is functional so we add
this line and then we get output but it
says no file system could mount root so
we have to tell it to enable the check
for external and it Rd which are these
two symbols and then it says it couldn't
execute bin SH so I have to basically
switch on config bin format elf so it
knows how to read an elf binary and then
then I get to the point where it reads
hello world in order to be able to do a
shell script I have to switch on config
bin format script and then I can run my
init script except it can't mount dev
Tempah it can't mount dev temp FS so I
have to switch on two symbols in order
to get the file system that gives me the
dev directories
and I I could I could go into more but
basically this is the kind of thing that
you know the the minimal set of symbols
that I was using for each target back in
4:3 he's github.com blandly back when I
was doing Aboriginal Linux the set of
symbols that I used for each target was
in the targets directory they're a bunch
of things like here's the one forearm v5
in order to boot a system I needed to
know what arch equals value to tell the
colonel when I built what path the
resulting bootable file would would show
up at that's for building GCC you don't
have to care about that what console
value to feed it because which which
console device am I using and then here
is the all no can here's the symbols I
added just for this architecture for
this board and the set of devices on
this board and here was the Kiwi mu
invocation I would use to to load it and
that set of symbols was actually added
to base config Linux which has more than
you actually need but these were the
common symbols that I would set on all
the targets so you can actually read
through and see what those symbols are
you don't need a lot of these and if I
if I had a little more time I'd go
through the here's the list of the ones
you need but unfortunately I am over
time I can probably take one or two
questions
I cannot okay oh sorry
somebody needs the room I'm sorry ask me
afterwards
[Applause]